there is no birth control for people
with penises
we made a covet vaccine in less than a
year
you are telling me we cannot get birth
control for people with penises
my name is gina silvanasi pronouns
i'm a sexuality and relationship
educator
hi my name is varuna i use shive
pronouns
i am a physician by training a public
health researcher
and i am interested in the intersections
between mental health and sexuality in
south asian cultures
and today we are busting myths around
sex and sexuality
these are myths from pop culture broken
hymen means a person has had sex before
no absolutely not yes some women do have
a hymen
and some women don't but i don't think
that we have scientifically
proven that a broken hymen is the test
of a virginity also
why is it that only people with vaginas
and high mens have this test what about
people with penises
i also want to call out rapper t.i men
like him go to the gynecologist and say
i need you to examine my daughter's
hymen once a year to make sure it's
intact
this is something that gets me really
aggravated this one definitely
contributes to
physical violence against folks with
vaginas less common
for people to have an intact hymen
and you know folks who do have a fully
intact hymen that
isn't helpful for themselves either when
it comes to you know if they're going to
start their period
the blood doesn't have anywhere to flow
and so
there are surgeries that folks would
have to undergo in order for that
the hymen to actually not be intact but
the way i see it that like you know you
have this like vaginal canal
right so say this is like the whole um
of the vagina
and this would be like a slightly intact
hymen in most cases
this is really what it what it would
look like
where it's still an opening right
but there's this would be like loose
skin
to me honestly it feels like a vestigial
organ it's the appendix of the vagina
i like to call it you don't really need
it
but it's there abstaining from sex makes
you better at sports
i'm assuming that again sex negative
culture
we don't want people to have sex and so
it's like well if you really want to be
good at basketball
you better not have sex with you know at
all because you're you want to reserve
all your
energy show that on the court but
there's no
as far as i know any study
that shows abstaining from sex is gonna
make you better at sports
yeah i haven't read any study either but
actually fun fact
in the rio olympics in 2016 more than
450 000
condoms were distributed so athletes
a lot of sex but i think if you're
responsible and you are having sex
responsibly in a consensual manner i
think why not
have fun have fun with sex and then go
play your game
your wallet is a great place for our
condom
[Laughter]
hey you got a condom on you i know you
have a condom in your wallet i think
that we've seen this right where they're
like oh i have a condom
in my wallet from 15 years ago honey
don't use that
more importantly condoms expire in like
five years there's like so check the
expiry date
never store it next to a sharp object
never store it
in a really humid place and never store
it and really
i think it's a tight place yeah your
wallet and if you're going out for booty
call you know you get that call and you
finally it's your moment to shine
just grab a couple of condoms put them
in your pocket sex
burns a lot of calories you know
depending on the kind of sex that you're
having
it can certainly burn calories i don't
think it's the equivalent
of you know running a marathon by any
means
it's not as excessive of amount the way
maybe people think of having like a
full 30 minute exercise because your
heart rate is not elevated to that
degree
the entire time yeah i totally agree
with you jada i think that there was a
recent time
article that came out that said that you
don't burn more than 100
calories uh in a single session of sex
but for the most part
do not do not think that this is your
workout it is a workout it gets your
heart rate pumping
but we would definitely recommend still
going to the gym and
maintaining an active lifestyle these
are myths
we hear the most there are only two
sexes
found in nature that is not true well i
think
a lot of times of like flowers flowers
that actually have both sexes
quote-unquote sexes within the flower in
itself
we have labeled them as male
and female we have to remember that
that's a classification that was
invented by humans
and i also think that this is one of
those dangerous
myths that's out there especially for
intersex persons because
doctors who who function in this idea
that there's only two sexes
do this corrective irreversible
corrective surgery
to decide if an intersex person is
quote-unquote male or quote-unquote
female for the rest of their life and
that can actually lead to a lot of
psychological problems
if someone is born intersex then they
should be given the choice to decide how
they want to live their lives what their
sexuality is
what sex they identify as what gender
they identify as
we definitely need to change this whole
ideology
a lot of people who still believe that
there are only two sexes in society will
go
towards science as their claim right and
science as their backup
and this is the part where we have to
remember that science is also
problematic sometimes
yeah this one's a tough one because it's
like it's not just changing the culture
it's literally changing the entire
system that taught us this culture
you can get an sti from a toilet seat
medically and technically and
scientifically speaking
the bacteria that does cause you know
syphilis and other
you know stis can only live in those
warm mucous membranes within your body
suppose we took that bacteria and we
you know put it on a toilet seat it
wouldn't live there for more than a
couple of hours it would die out
so it's impossible for someone to go and
sit on it
and then get that infection and you also
cannot get pregnant
from sitting on a toilet seat either the
word sti
sexually transmitted infection and so
it's sexually transmitted between
bodies only older people should need
lube oh god now we get into the ageist
myths
i just want to be like no it's not true
everyone can benefit from using lube
it's honestly i think the most
underrated sex
accessory if you don't purchase anything
else
please purchase lube this is for people
of all ages
so a lot of people with uteruses who go
through menopause
when you have decreased estrogen it
reduces the vaginal lubrication
and our body does have natural vaginal
lubricants
so having sex during that time can be
painful
can be hard and can be uncomfortable
really
and don't use vaseline so you don't want
to put lotions which is meant to be on
your skin your external skin
the vagina the has a mucous membrane um
it comes it's
completely different from the skin on
your body water base is going to
probably be the safest bet
for your own body and depending on if
you decide to use toy it's usually not
recommended to use
silicone lube with silicone toys
plastic can react to plastic yeah it's
also definitely not recommended to use
oil based lubes with condoms because you
can't risk breaking
sex equals penetration oh gosh
people get to have their own definitions
of sex i think a lot of times we think
that sex
equals penetration because you're using
a vagina
and a penis but obviously that is very
heteronormative and doesn't apply to
every single
partnered relationship right and just
because
it's not a vagina and a penis having sex
doesn't
mean it's not sex we actually use our
entire body
during sex and so when we equate sex to
only these two pieces of our bodies
it's not accurate oh my god you kneel on
the head what we really say when we mean
sex is not that it's just penetration
like you said penis and vagina but it's
really just an experience
that helps you get in touch with your
sexuality that helps you form a deeper
connection with the other person
if you get an sti you can't get it again
you can totally get the same sti a
second time
even after you have been you know cured
from it
and not all stis are curable put it out
there that even hiv
there is such a thing as reinfections
and super infections is when you get a
different strain of the same virus
superimposed on the illness that you
have from the first strain of the virus
that can depending on your body
physiology your wbc count
can lead you to get a higher infection
or a different type of infection
please go get tested we want to
destigmatize it but we also want to
encourage disclosure
um but it's important for people to know
if you have an sti
it's like even letting people know that
you are on birth control are not on
birth control
giving people the information so that
when they do consent it is fully
informed
there is no treatment for hiv
um okay let's talk about this i think
that this is a genuine myth that many
people
i think it's a question that many people
have and there is no ultimate cure for
for hiv but there does exist an
antiretroviral therapy
that as soon as you are diagnosed with
hiv you can go on those medications and
they are supposed to help you lead
a longer and a healthier life um and
there is
also prap i think that you know the
pre-exposure prophylaxis which you can
take if you are
at risk for hiv or if your partner is at
risk for hiv
so scientists are working really hard to
find a cure
you know this myth comes from that
history of
folks who were dying without treatment
and a lot of times when you think about
why the government didn't rush right to
create treatment it's because it was
mostly affecting queer folks
and so i'm thankful that now we do
have treatment for it not necessarily a
cure
and it's mostly again pushed by queer
folks in the lgbtq community
i think when we have a fear around an
sti we almost like want to avoid it
sometimes because we don't want to
confirm
the worst case scenario for ourselves
but again
we don't want to wait longer because we
don't want the infection
to get worse over time if you do have a
partner
or have sexual partners and you do
contract hiv
then doing enough research together so
that
folks can kind of again goes back to
informed consent so that folks can have
all the information that they can
around this particular issue blue balls
is caused by
sexual arousal without orgasm
this is an absolute myth in that i don't
think that if if
you think of people with testicles
actually got blue balls they would think
that all they needed to do was to have
an orgasm
and they wouldn't take anything else
seriously about their health
and b um i think it's also rooted in
sexual coercion
right because there's often that
statement where you know the person
the other person is like i don't want to
have sex anymore and then they're like
oh honey come on you're giving me blue
balls over here
at least like get me off you know at
least let me finish
if you need to like let up some steam if
you have
access to a bathroom definitely go in
there
and masturbate don't make the other
person feel uncomfortable
so if you've ever seen your fingertips
turn blue or your lips turn blue it
usually means that you have decreased
oxygen to that part of the body
um if that happens to your testicles i
would call 9-1-1 or i would go into the
doctor immediately
sexual arousal like you're going to get
blood flow to to your genitals that's
kind of how it happens right you're
going to get blood that that goes to
there and so i can understand that maybe
it might be
uncomfortable it'll flow right back even
if you don't have an orgasm
assigned male at birth amab and assigned
female at birth afab
hit their quote unquote sexual peak at
different ages
people have sexual peaks all throughout
their ages at different times of their
life i think that sexual energy is
something you can maintain across your
life
and some people maybe don't have a lot
of it some people do
there's too many different environmental
factors cultural factors
kind of internal factors that play a
role into
your sexual energy and your sexual
arousal you know sexual desire i think
is dependent on age and hormones to a
big extent
i think for many people it could be
their teams when you're like 25 for some
people you could even hit it at like 45
with decreased estrogen you have
decreased desire
increased testosterone you have
increased desire
decreased progesterone there can be
increased desire i don't think it's fair
to gender it and to say that
men and women have their sexual peak at
different ages having this idea of
sexual peak excludes people who identify
as being asexual
watching porn when you're young can
cause erectile dysfunction
the mainstream sort of pawn videos show
us are these really like
unrealistic bodies we've also seen
people having
abnormally large penises having
erections for longer than 30 minutes
the usual time you can have an erection
is like 5 to 30 minutes
and you know coming multiple times these
sort of create an idea within like young
minds that my penis is supposed to be
long it's supposed to be big
it's supposed to give so much pleasure
to someone and that
you know i should have a heart on for
like an hour and i think what
these can do is cause a lot of anxiety
and you sort of like
there's this thing called spectatoring
which is that you are essentially having
an out-of-body experience where you're
trying to watch yourself having sex and
i think anxiety and depression is
actually one of
the causes of erectile dysfunction
because we live in a sex negative
culture
a lot of us have internalized really
negative ideas about what it
means to be in our bodies and what it
means to have sex and how we're supposed
to perform
so i could see those as more direct
contributors to erectile dysfunction
than just strictly watching porn and now
we're on to
myths from social media masturbation
is bad for you this is a question that i
definitely get a lot young men
on instagram dm me and say that they
masturbate x number of times a day and
if it's bad for them
it is good for you it has been proven to
release endorphins and i think that
you are building on a relationship with
yourself there's no risks of stis
there's no risk of pregnancy when you
masturbate right make sure whatever
you're using to masturbate is clean
it's really like the least harmful way
to enjoy
sexual pleasure so i think most of these
are like meant to shame you or scare you
vaginas stretch out with use
they don't stretch out with youth you
know the vaginal canal is a muscle
and our muscles do stretch and contract
so when something is inserted into the
vagina
or when things come out like a human
baby
then it can stretch they don't
necessarily lose their
elasticity but elasticity can change
over time
with age with estrogen levels decreasing
which causes the vaginal tissue to get
thinner or drier
that applies to all the muscles in our
body all the muscles in our body change
over time
i also want to state that this is also a
particularly harmful myth i think that
this is also
deeply rooted in the patriarchy that you
need to have the smallest
tightest hole for penetration and that
you know the tighter it is the more
pleasure it gives for your partner dr
jennifer gunter had like this amazing
tweet and it said that if
if by your logic the vagina stretches
out after every use then the penis
should be a flabby balloon after the use
right because of every erection
but you don't hear anyone talking about
that you know there are actually people
who struggle
with their vaginal canal not
opening up or not stretching or it is a
little bit smaller and that causes so
much
pain that's a condition in itself
and so for us to think that it's
something we should strive for
you know is really harmful as well and
kind of erases people who struggle
with that particular condition mountain
dew
lower sperm count who comes up with
these
i i want to know i just want to talk
let's talk
a i don't think that it lowers the sperm
count and b
you have other things to worry about if
you're drinking copious amounts of
mountain view
there are a lot of other things that can
cause a low sperm count
it comes down to temperature age any
recent injuries
whether you've had any sort of
testicular problems
as a child growing up also drinking
copious amounts of alcohol
or you know smoking a lot of cigarettes
can also lower your sperm count
does it come from a place of shame of
trying to get people
not to drink mountain dew or does it
come from a place of
someone using it as an excuse to not use
a condom
that's not gonna get you pregnant just
because it lowers my sperm count
you know what we would recommend is just
that you have a
healthy diet so that your body is
functionally
functioning as normal as it can if your
sperm is ever yellowish
that's a concern the consistency changes
drastically
for whatever reason and that's a concern
i wouldn't necessarily equate that to
like
a specific food there is no birth
control
for people with penises so i think a lot
of times people equate
the word birth control with hormonal
birth control but birth control and
contraceptives
include things like condoms another one
is
like a vasectomy a vasectomy is a form
of birth control
and something that people with penises
can also undergo
there has been clinical trials of
an injection for people with penises um
unfortunately that hasn't reached the
united states yet
birth control definitely exists with
people with penises i think that as sex
educators we are
advocating every single day for shared
responsibility
the other day you want to protect
yourself we made a covet vaccine
in less than a year you are telling me
we cannot get
birth control for people with penises if
you are
someone who is young who's watching this
and you believed any of these myths it's
totally okay it's really the system
until we live
in a truly sex positive patriarchy
free anti-racist society
then we're not going to get to a place
where we can have true sexual liberation